you are watching The Press preview from
Buckingham Palace a first look at what's
on the front pages as they arrive so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages for you now
the telegraph's headline Devotion to
duty the paper leads with the thousands
queuing to honor the queen as King
Charles and his siblings stand vigil
the sun leads with the same their
headline King and Country say farewell
vigil for Mama leads the Daily Mail
picturing the king and his siblings
standing vigil
the same image is on the front of the
express their headline we're here with
you always ma'am
the times also reports on the vigil held
by the Queen's children in what they
call an emotional end to a week of
national Mourning
the star focuses on the long cue for
people to pay their respects to the
queen and the second cue that was formed
the guardian leads with comments from
the fiancee of murdered journalist Jamal
khashoggi condemning Plans by the Crown
Prince of Saudi Arabia to visit London
to pay respects to the queen
the eye turns its attention to the cost
of living their headline and mortgage
hike for Millions as the pound Falls
the Ft also leads with the pound falling
to its lowest level since 1985 against
the dollar
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
chief executive of conservative home and
Mark Wallace and Senior associate editor
at the new Statesman Rachel canliff
welcome to you both let us start with
the telegraph
and their front page the headline their
devotion to duty Rachel well very
powerful image there of the new king and
his siblings standing vigil uh for their
their late mother and you can see the
thousands coming in to to pay their
respects so while this moment of very
personal sort of intimate moment of of
grief occurring at the same time you've
got the public sort of response to it
which kind of sums up what we've had
this week really we've had the official
events we've had uh the the new king
going around the to the four nations uh
in a series of very sort of stylized
formal addresses and you've had the
public reaction first in in Edinburgh
and now in London making it really clear
that this is a an event that almost the
whole country feels feels part of many
of them thousands of them prepared to to
wait for hours up to 24 hours to really
be part of it and Mark you've certainly
got that sense of the the family
themselves handing over the queen to the
public when she was taken to to
Westminster Hall yes and I think
particularly looking at this scene with
the King and his siblings they're
joining the guard of Honor for their
mother as she lies in state in this
place of such deep history you know this
is this is in a building that it was
built by the son of William the
Conqueror this is on the spot where
Charles the first was tried and and
sentenced to death this is a room where
Henry VIII played tennis
um and you have this great sense of
continuity when people talk you know we
talk abstractly about a thousand year
monarchy this is visibly the transition
in in that it's a really remarkable
scene but you do though have the the
personal moment it seemed like a
personal moment with her children
standing guard holding the vigil but
then streams of people flowing past
hardly a private moment but it did still
seem to be I think the amount of
pressure on all of them particularly on
King Charles to to have that balance
obviously they are grieving uh a mother
the the grandchildren are all holding
vigil tonight grieving a grandparent
we've had some very moving tributes from
different members of of the royal family
but still having those ceremonial roles
and pretty much with a couple of
exceptions uh not not filtering in in
that in that whole week that we've seen
it's sort of a reminder that they are
dealing with a a personal bereavement at
that time and also I think there's
something sort of Mark was talking about
the history of the room the history of
the Traditions there's this quite
interesting juxtaposition because these
are uh Traditions that are hundreds of
years old and have applied to various
monarchs throughout Britain's history
but we haven't seen them for for 70
years so for vast majority of the
country this is the first time we're
experienced everything that was the
first time a lot of them have been
televised so bringing modern technology
and bringing the cameras into quite
intimate moments and and into that that
moment of History
um you were you were there today weren't
you I went I was very fortunate last
night actually to get to spend half an
hour observing uh people paying their
respect in in Westminster Hall and it's
it was fascinating particularly for two
reasons firstly you're covering politics
you see Parliament and the the
Parliamentary estate in every kind of
mood you see it you know um dolled up
and locked down empty busy angry uh
bound up in politics or tourism I
thought I'd seen it in every mood that
it had and actually this is a completely
obvious reasons you Unique Kind of mode
um The Silence
sounds obviously it's very hard to
describe the mood in in Westminster but
actually that really personal every
single person who came through watching
over the course of half an hour you see
hundreds and hundreds of people
everybody had their own way of
commemorating that moment to paying
their own personal respects you know you
saw people from the Armed Forces or the
Emergency Services people bringing
very very new babies or very very
elderly each having their own personal
moment there and that is part of you
know the fact that this is a personal
Mentor as a statement to live our family
as you say and actually it's it's part
of that that relationship I think they
have with the wider public that they
they too have that individual moment and
interesting that you say that that each
person moving along had their own
particular private moment
there is no rule book is there there is
no particular etiquette that they will
have been told that they should carry
out an empty treating the moment
individually
one thing that has been very very clear
is no phones allowed and you can see in
the in the footage I'm sure you you saw
it sort of last night the difference
that that that makes having a moment
that is entirely about being in the
moment and personal reflection not
people trying to get photos while you
try and get photos anyway when some of
the country's best photographers are
there getting their own professional
photos is another matter but that it's
not about the technology it's not about
people's uh taking a photograph to show
off or to have that it's about personal
reflection and making a memory and
marking that moment in people's own way
and the Sun that highlighting what we've
been saying and their headlanking in
country say farewell
the personal grief and loss of the the
royal family but also loss for the
country
absolutely and I I think quite a lot of
people have been surprised the the
degree to which they've been personally
deeply touched and moved by what's
happened
um in a variety of these different
events over the course of the last week
of official morning you know the number
of times you you anecdotally you speak
to people and they say well we knew that
this day would come eventually
um but actually even then the way it
struck people the depth of feeling I
think has taken quite a lot of people
regardless even of their political views
on the Constitution and so on their
personal connection with with the queen
has really taken some people back and a
lot of people have related it to that to
their own lives you know they might have
suffered a bereavement themselves or
it's you know the queen reminded them of
their grandmother or their mother so
it's not only the grief for the loss of
the queen it's also they've been
relating it to their personal
circumstances as well yes and I think
the the two years of covert and lockdown
probably has had an impact as well uh
all those missed events having to do
funerals spot via Zoom I think uh well
that was obviously very necessary that
may have sort of cemented in people's
minds The Importance of Being that in
person and that sort of collective uh
experience and I I think there was that
on that feature that I think the
guardian did a few years ago that was in
London Bridge that was sort of laying
out what would happen all the plans for
when when the queen did eventually uh
pass away and one of the lines in that
was people who don't think they're going
to cry will cry and that was sort of
predicted and I think that's kind of
inevitable when obviously the vast
majority of us didn't know her never met
her but when something that has been a
sort of fundamental backdrop to your
life changes even if you know it's
inevitable even if you know it's going
to happen it's still a shock and the
sort of national reaction to that is is
I think partly what's behind in the 24
hour several mile long queue that we're
seeing in London
it's things like it's underappreciated
particularly by observers from countries
that don't have a don't have a monarchy
it's quite it's underappreciated from
outside it's quite hard to explain the
degree to which of course the royal
family in all sorts of ways aren't like
us but in the most fundamental ways they
are they are a family they are and
though the nation does routinely
identify an awful lot of people around
the country identify with those same
familial experiences marriage birth
death morning and that's exactly why
people identify it's not only it's not
only the queen who people identified as
their grandmother you read back in
history you find an awful lot of people
over centuries have felt this way in
identifying the kind of rhythms of life
that you see on a national stage beneath
the Pomp and Circumstance this this is a
family which sits at the heart of the
nation
are you nonetheless surprised by the
outpouring of of grief and the lengths
that people are prepared to to go to to
actually pay their their final respects
queuing for for hours and hours and
hours and end well I was at first and I
probably shouldn't have been you
predicted that the queue would uh become
a story sort of in and of it of itself
uh and obviously it has done and I was
sort of a bit bemused by it but I went
down there yesterday and I sort of
walked along about a mile of it and I
talked to people who were in it and sort
of two things struck me one was that the
mood was
not cheerful but sort of not stressed
not anxious this wasn't the cue normally
people get a bit stressed when they're
cute they get a bit sort of
I don't know antsy about it everyone in
that queue was very content to be in the
queue there was a steward who said three
to four hours to go now and everyone
went good okay
um which is sort of an interesting mood
and what's wrong because expectations
had been set so they knew that it wasn't
going to be a Quick Queue but I think it
was it was more than that because you
can leave the queue with a wristband and
come back and theoretically I imagine
you could leave for quite some time and
come back but people aren't and I think
actually the act of standing in the
queue there was somebody who said
um you know it's it's a personal Act of
service in recognition of the acts of
service that the queen performed over
her life and so actually spending that
time in the queue is in itself something
that people feel quite proud to be doing
regardless of what happens at the end of
it I suppose Marcus is a little bit like
wearing a hair shirt isn't it going
through that experience and part of your
discomfort shows your your commitment to
the queen well as a lot of people have
noted though there's quite deep
Resonance of pilgrimage in in some parts
this that kind of whether you're
religious or not that kind of Heritage
of
um going on a journey and going on a
journey with other people in order to
commemorate I think that that idea of
that feeling that commemoration is a
collective thing and I think you're
absolutely right that particularly
during the the pandemic periods when
people were compelled to go through a
traumatic experience not together was in
in many ways made it all the harder and
these opportunities whether it's in the
queue whether it's people at Major
sporting events singing the National
Anthem together whether it's a shared
minute of Silence that collective
experience I we uh my wife and I brought
our children just just over there the
gates of Buckingham Palace last Saturday
we intended to come by for an hour lay
flowers and see what was that we ended
up staying for eight and a half hours
with but with with a bunch of other
people who are complete strangers around
you you share the experience together
and you do remember well
almost certainly never cross paths again
but actually that memory is part of that
experience
um just as the crowd who are on the mall
when for the Platinum Jubilee exactly
the same thing is it's something that's
experienced together as a communal Act
of mourning has its own kind of value
and power and benefit to people
the the star Rachel meanwhile is poking
a little bit of fun at the uh the cues
with with their headline
um because there was a sub queue QE2 is
is their pun deceiving oh I kind of
think that you do need moments of levity
as well right and if you think about it
it's not with an abstract the cue is
quite a strange thing uh there have been
people who one of my colleagues at the
estatesman has written a sort of science
fiction story about the queue you've had
people pointing out that you might have
uh new relationships romances
flourishing in the queue maybe Richard
curses will one day make a film about
the queue Like Love Actually this sort
of strangers coming together and meeting
and I think it's it's strange right it's
a living monument in and of itself but
fundamentally I think it's people
realizing this is a key moment of
history and wanting to be part of it and
if that means having to queue for the
queue I think you've got a sky reporter
who's there at the intersection of the
two queues where the Q4 the queue
becomes the queue itself that's just
part of the story it's part of the The
Legend and I imagine that the queue will
be in the history books when a
historians come to reflect on this quite
strange week in British history let's
face it Mark Ewing is part of the
culture isn't it absolutely if you're
going to choose one final sport in the
world which were still dominant at it's
queuing and as soon as they announced
that the queue was closed obviously
there was going to be a cue to join the
queue I mean you know what this this is
written after all and um I I I like the
fact that this reflects
obviously reflects people's dedication
to want to to wanting to pay their
respects but let's be honest everyone
who's in the queue to join the queue is
having a bit of a chortle together about
the fact they've managed to to do it
twice but but I mean you're you're right
about people forming relationships
during the course of the day um Harry
Potter's have been in the queue with
various people who'd never met before
and have actually formed such strong
bonds that they've decided that they're
going to complete the queue together and
they'll be swapping numbers and forming
new relationships and friendships
I was going to say for some lucky people
the uh I don't know if you accept his
number with anyone but he was he was
there for over 10 hours I think I don't
think it was yeah about 13 13 hours and
curiously all by himself it seemed
throughout well I think he had various
people coming to take pictures with him
at at various points but yeah it's a
it's a leveling experience isn't it and
he was quite emotional when he actually
got into uh Westminster Hall and I think
we'd be caught on camera shed a tear
well I think that's interesting as well
so the people who I know who've
completed with the Q experience as it
were have all said that the experience
of being in the queue there's a lot of
camaraderie there's a lot of sort of
cheerfulness and getting to know people
and then suddenly you were in
Westminster Hall and the mood changes
completely it's very silent it's very
moving obviously as I said no phones
sort of no talking and you get that
reflection and then when they come out
of it again
there's quite a sort of strong emotional
response to that and you can sort of see
that with with David Beckham but also
with a lot of the people in that footage
yeah and interesting David Beckham was
offered um a shortcut a short route by
the uh
the authorities there the people
looking after the queue and uh he
refused
and he's an awful lot of people have no
kind of noted that and praised his kind
of decision to do that as part of that
leveling experience just just just as
you say and that that moment as you said
I think that that moment when people
step into the Hall it is definitely
noticeable when you're when when you
watch people kind of filing through
Westminster Hall when they arrive
it kind of can step into the building
that kind of somber mode I think people
struggle you can see people struggling
to work out exactly how they feel about
it and you can you know from literally
from Vickers to punks yesterday you saw
people kind of you know got a motive
dust in their eye and got the one thing
they all had in common is that everybody
gets to the exit and
stops for a second and looks back to
kind of take the scene in one last time
let's move on to what the king's been
doing today and he's been in Wales uh
the times Pages four and five have got a
spread on this and and he spoke of his
his love for Wales I mean he was a
prince of Wales for an awfully long time
he spoke of his love for Wales in Welsh
which the the times he's reporting is
first didn't he yes uh the longest
speech given by a monarch in Welsh since
uh that of Queen Elizabeth the first I
think and obviously he has been one one
of the the consequences of the queen
having such a long Reign is he has had a
very long tenure as Prince of Wales and
it's it's clear that that's somewhere
that
um he has a lot of
affection and devotion for and they act
as well as passing the mantle of Prince
of Wales onto his son is something that
he was also quite emotional about
well it's yes it it it's remarkable to
think to see Elizabeth the first as we
were saying before obviously her father
was Welsh and she she was you know
raised effectively in a kind of
anglo-welsh uh family
um but this has been a punishing tour as
well a dedication and Duty uh for for
the new king you know he's he's as we
say he's grieving he's lost his uh
beloved mother he's become the Monarch
uh and he's you know has a 10-day kind
of uh process of visiting each of the
home Nations they're spending an awful
lot of time I think to their credit
meeting people who've come to see them
who've come to pay their respects taking
that time to
um you know exchange words with the
public it hasn't seen rushed at all has
it and they've been you know over
scheduled because they've taken that
time to speak to people and he
you must you must be exhausted by now
and you know that in that dichotomy as
you were saying earlier the kind of the
the official nature of these
responsibilities but in a period of
personal loss must be unimaginably
difficult
let's um oh just one thing in in Wales I
don't know if you're aware of the um the
person the man in the crowd who um had
said that you know taxpayers are going
to have to pay for this visit and we
can't afford it with the cost of living
crisis
did you did you see that I saw that
there was a protester I just saw some
reports there being a kind of Soul what
did you make of that
I think it's valid questions to be asked
at the moment especially on the backdrop
of the the cost of living crisis and
it's it it is
um
that's something that I think will have
a natural conversation about
subsequently is how protesters have been
dealt with over the last sort of week or
just not even protested just people who
have a different view of the monarchy
and how they get the time and space to
express that within the context of this
sort of national morning period but the
cost of living crisis was something that
the the King which is still a very
strange thing to be saying but the the
king addressed with Mark David and I
think because he has obviously been
waiting for this moment for a very long
time he does have an understanding of
how things look uh the the state of of
the country how difficult life is going
to be for an awful lot of people and an
awareness that in a constitutional
monarchy you kind of have to that
there's a the messaging is important and
the Optics were important and I think he
does have an awareness of that hence
those statements should we take a look
at that clip for those that might have
missed it
[Applause]
thank you for coming
for you
[Music]
yes Mark he clearly heard what was said
didn't he yes but that's part of the the
nature one of the many good things about
the nation in which we live something
like that can actually happen there's
quite a lot of countries in the world
where even your political leaders
um a letter or otherwise wouldn't
wouldn't hear something like that never
mind uh a a monarchical head of state
um exactly as Rachel says frankly there
have been moments in recent days I'm a
monarchist but as I think it's probably
evident from the conversation we've had
this evening but there have been times
in recent days where some of the
decision making by police Scotland or
the Metropolitan Police frankly has been
excessive and heavy-handed with people
who've protested or in some cases not
even protested been warned off on
suspicion of maybe expressing an opinion
I don't think anybody really wants that
to be the case I very much doubt that
the Royals particularly want want that
to be kind of forbidden or clam town is
quite counterproductive so I think it's
healthy people have the right to express
opinions like that I think were I that
gentleman I'd probably question whether
I'm doing my cause a huge favor by uh
choosing that particular moment with
with a kind of grieving uh Monarch but
that's your right it's in the ear to the
nature of the country in which we live
Rachel you've got about 30 seconds a
little less actually just tell us about
the mortgage hike uh for Millions that's
about to hit the uh the NBC obviously
have pushed back their scheduled meeting
a week out of sort of respect for
the queen but that doesn't mean that
interest rates aren't going up they are
that is to combat inflation but that is
unfortunately going to be yet another a
thing pushing up the the cost of living
for Millions across the country